president Trump the only declared or I
think he's the only did Mike Pence
officially say he's running or he just
said he's probably going to run Nikki
Haley just said she's probably going to
run Joe Biden has now declared that he's
running but he's obviously not
campaigning yet Trump is running he's
declared he's hit
New Hampshire and South Carolina here is
the campaign message from New Hampshire
when I announced I just want to put my
cards in the table like you know we're
playing that very big game right now the
biggest game of all because it involves
the country and the survival of the
United States of America but when I uh
when I put the cards on and then I said
all right let's go they said he's not
campaigning this is like
about a month ago when I announced well
I said you know I get two years
they said he's not doing rallies he's
not campaigning maybe he's lost that
step I wouldn't I'm more angry now and
I'm more committed now than I ever was
because
Okay so
Trump is acknowledging the criticism of
his campaign and his campaign loss
and it would seem that he's reacting to
it too because he starts now doing
events but he didn't do a big rally this
was an event really for locals and the
Republican leadership in New Hampshire
and then he says this line I'm angrier
now
than I've ever been before
but the way he says it he doesn't seem
angry
nor necessarily should he seem angry
he's Trump running in 2024 is a very
different thing than Trump running in
2016. he's a different person he's got
different experience he brings a
different ethos to the whole to the
whole matter but you you can the only
thing you can really tell I think I
agree with Trump he's got two years I
agree that a lot of the criticism of
this campaign is BS I agree that it's
mostly just people on the left and the
right who hate his guts and the people
on the left are trying to stop him from
running and the people on the right who
are attacking him now probably in most
cases are people who hated him in 2016
also so all of that is true but
I think it is fair to say he doesn't
seem to have the same fire he doesn't
seem to have the same focus when he came
down that escalator in 2015 he said the
the illegal aliens they're rapists and
they're murderers they're being sent
across we need to build a big wall and
Deport all these people who are invading
our country
love it or hate it that's a clear
message we're getting screwed on trade
deals we're going to stick it to China
we're going to completely upend
America's trade policy love it or hate
it that is a very clear message it
distinguished him from the others in the
crowd
now just by virtue of the fact that he
was already the president it's it's
going to be harder to distinguish
himself from the rest of the party he
recreated the party after his own image
so I think he's going to have to try
something different he then hit South
Carolina and announced a big leadership
team and he got a big endorsement from
that state senator Lindsey Graham
there's one thing I want to talk to you
about
how many
how many times have you heard we like
Trump
uh policies but we want somebody new
there are no Trump policies without
Donald Trump
I was there
you know why 400 billion
dollars given by NATO Nations because he
asked and they were afraid to say no
up there is asked NATO to give more
money but they gave more money when he
asked
people talk about China you did
something about China they finally paid
everybody's been talking about China you
made them pay you know why Mexico said
yes to you because you scared the hell
out of them by taking on China we live
in a dangerous world right now
the good news for the Republican party
there are many many talented people for
years to come but there is only one
Donald Trump
and I say this sincerely
you can talk about his policies but you
could not do what he did
this is the message that Trump has to
drive home and it's funny that it's
coming from Lindsey Graham because
Lindsey Graham is considered kind of a
Squish and they call him Lindsey
gramnisty and all sorts of things and
Graham was very opposed to Trump in
2016. he obviously ran against him then
he became much more supportive of Donald
Trump and I don't care if you love
Lindsey Graham or you hate Lindsey
Graham One Lindsey Graham is a great
trial lawyer and he's very good at
getting himself re-elected and he's he's
just a very talented politician even if
you think he's a big squish lib and so
the fact that Lindsey Graham is putting
his money on Donald Trump
does tell you a little something about a
political calculation Lindsey Graham
feels that the political wind is still
blowing in the direction of Donald Trump
and Lindsey Ramsey hit on the campaign
message that Trump needs which is there
is no trumpism without Trump
the DeSantis campaign message is there
is trumpism without Trump I am the
better version of trump I am more
disciplined I am better educated I am I
I'm better able to make deals I'm less
polarizing I'm whatever the whole list
of Ron desantis's campaign pitch
it essentially boils down to I am Trump
but better and so Trump's campaign
message has to be there is no better
Trump I'm I'm Trump I'm unique I'm an
American original there's nobody like me
there's a lot of imitators out there but
I'm the only one who can do it and even
if we both have the same policies
I can get it done and there's more to
politics than just policy on a sheet of
paper I can get it done
now what DeSantis argument is going to
be actually I got it done better than
you did
and then Trump's argument is going to be
you could never have done any of that
without me one you wouldn't have gotten
elected without me but two if I didn't
give you political cover from the
national level you wouldn't have been
able to do a good job as governor and
that's going to be the battle
but but if the issue it just comes down
to issues I don't know that Trump is
going to win
because the party and the smart
politicians in the party
have taken a page out of Trump's book
and adopted his positions on issues
positions that seven eight years ago
would not have been acceptable on
immigration on trade on the the
involvement of the government and the
daily lives of Americans that would not
have been on foreign policy for that
matter
so the only way that Trump can
distinguish himself is by saying I'm the
one who can do it I do it in a different
way the fact that I am polarizing the
fact that I am Brash the fact that I am
unpredictable the fact that I'm not
totally educated in this uh politician
University kind of way
that is my plot it's not a negative
that's my plus and that's the message
that Lindsey Graham has honed in on and
I think it's a very strong one if he can
if he can make a persuasive case for
that thesis the nomination probably is
still his don't forget we're talking
about especially Rhonda Sanders because
he's just so impressive in Florida
you're seeing desantis's numbers shoot
up out of nowhere up to a pretty
respectable number
now what is he now he's at 30 or
something even higher but
Trump is still way up
the the primary contest remains trumps
to lose but he's got some big weaknesses
especially when it comes to covid which
we'll get to in one second right now go
to geniusell.com Knowles our friends
over at geniusell skincare have exciting
news to celebrate in 2023. they are
introducing their new microbiome
moisturizer which uses the power of
probiotics to Target skin redness pesky
wrinkles Fine Lines patchy blotches and
other signs of premature aging these are
the same probiotics that are in your
yogurt as it turns out these super
ingredients can have the same nourishing
benefits on your skin as they do in your
gut probiotic extracts Target bad
bacteria and restore balance to your
Skin's protective barrier now every
genucel most popular package includes
their new probiotic moisturizer free
with your order I love these guys I'm
always skeptical
of cosmetic creams and ointments so I
said okay before I endorse I want to see
this product I want to have it for
myself so that I can try it on my own
face and I really really trust these
guys okay right now you can get gen
yourself's most popular package for 70
off 7-0 go to genyourself.com Knowles
get your probiotic moisturizer today use
code Knolls kwels at checkout for an
extra 10 off your entire purchase
geniusell.com Knowles that is
genucel.com Knowles Senator Ron Johnson
is standing up for the vaccine injured
he says the vaccine injured deserves to
be seen heard and believed
and then he tags a news agency says are
you aware of the covid-19 vaccine
injuries in the aviation industry
my letter highlights five of these
severe Adverse Events experienced by
pilots and an air traffic controller so
you got Ron Johnson has this this letter
that he's put out and and it's now being
reported in a number of places including
the epoch times of of Pilots
specifically who all had to get the
stupid fouchy ouchy and many of whom
have suffered adverse uh events now
he says well it remains unclear what if
anything the FAA has done as it relates
to these individuals experiences or if
it is actively monitoring covid-19
adverse effects in the aviation industry
as of January 13th there's the vaccine
adverse event Reporting System recorded
more than one and a half million adverse
effects and 33 746 deaths associated
with the covid-19 vaccines and
I think a lot of people hear that number
from bears and they say oh well verus is
unverified and so that's that number is
actually probably overblown no it's the
opposite time and time again we see
evidence that veres actually drastically
under reports
vaccine injuries
now think about this do you know anyone
in your life
who has suffered a vaccine injury or do
you know someone who knows someone who
suffered a vaccine injury
most people I think do I certainly do
and I think most people know someone or
know someone who knows someone who
suffered a vaccine injury then ask
yourself did that person file a report
with the vaccine Adverse Events
reporting system
usually not
most people will not do or even you
might say well I got my kid got this
vaccine and then things started to seem
a little weirder yeah I started to have
these I don't know kind of shortness of
breath or heart problems or this or that
but I'm not gonna I don't know I don't
want to seem like a crazy person so
there's under reports that how many
people actually died from this vaccine
Vera says 33 746 I bet that number is
much much higher in addition a
Department of Defense whistleblower
provided Ron Johnson's office with data
quote showing an increase in disease and
injuries in Pilots across the dod in
years 2020 to 2022 compared to years
2016 to 2019.
now there will be debate they'll you'll
hear the libs say well no the the the
adverse effects were caused by the the
virus not by the vaccine no no it's just
a virus you know the virus was
everywhere it's caused by the virus not
the vaccine
that merits some study because what what
little evidence is available now doesn't
seem to suggest that and furthermore the
fact that we're not even allowed to
raise that question
tells you I think everything you need to
know the fact that if you raise that
question
you can in many circumstances be kicked
off of social media
you will be looked on as as a as an
idiot
you'll you'll be called a misinformer
you'll you'll be accused of of
committing something tantamount to
murder
because you're spreading Health
misinformation
and then to tie it back to the political
2024 question this is Trump's biggest
weakness
and this is I suspect we're DeSantis and
any other challenges are going to hit
Trump the hardest
as they're going to say you promoted
this vaccine
this vaccine was bad news
and so what Trump is going to do and
you're already starting to see this is
Trump is going to start to hit DeSantis
there he's going to say do you promoted
the vaccine too
and you locked down too don't pretend
that you didn't lock down you locked
down for months
and you're already seeing Trump start to
make that attack so even now 2024 this
will be four years after covet 19.
I strongly suspect that much of the
Republican primary is going to come down
to covid we are still processing the
covid lockdowns
and and we think we've moved on because
we don't wear the stupid hankies anymore
over our face and even the people who
formerly took were very afraid of covid
and who promoted the vaccines and who
even
most of those people virtually all of
those people on the right have come back
to reality and said okay actually yeah
that was crazy we shouldn't have given
up our rights we shouldn't have locked
down shouldn't have worn the stupid
hanky shouldn't have taken the vouchi
algae okay all right fine but
just because the people on the right now
broadly agree on on what we should have
done
it doesn't mean that we're past it that
was a national trauma people died alone
people were not allowed to say goodbye
to their loved ones kids were taken out
of school it's seriously damaged their
education and their socialization
the the good news about taking kids out
of school is that it it prevented them
from learning a bunch of insane nonsense
from their woke teachers that was a good
thing it prevented their socialization
in the sense that it stopped them from
becoming socialists more quickly but it
it did seriously harm the fact that kids
weren't allowed to see their friends
seriously harmed their development
destroyed our economy destroyed small
businesses with largest transfer of
wealth in recorded history from the
lower classes to the upper classes it
was a major transfer of our political
rights
away from communities and away from
American citizens toward unelected
unaccountable bureaucrats who hate our
guts
we're still we've still got to Grapple
with that today is music Monday the rest
of the show continues now Mr Davies and
the producing team
has some really profound music for me to
analyze because you know I am a cultural
Maven I am this the hip-hop pippity pop
kind of music man over here you don't
want to miss it become a member and use
code knowleskin wlas at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans we'll
see you over there
[Music]
foreign